[Musique]
ce 2 novembre le président du
Département Cyril Maker a visité 4
exploitations situées dans la zone de
l'antenne 4 de l'irrigation du littoral
ouest le département accompagne le
développement agricole au travers de son
plan agrippé 2030 si nous voulons d'une
agriculture performante et tente vers la
souveraineté alimentaire nous devons
récupérer le maximum de théâtre en
friche c'est cela un objectif majeur
pour le département installez de jeunes
agriculteurs récupérer les terres en
fiche et accompagner les agriculteurs
qui sont déjà en activité depuis
plusieurs années et moi je salue si le
travail partenarial réalisé en CBO
territorias le département mais aussi
les agriculteurs la Chambre
d'Agriculture et la SAFER nous sommes
dans la démonstration que quand on
travaille ensemble nous sommes capables
de pousser l'agriculture réunionnaise
vers les hauts sommets en termes de
qualité de rendement et de production
soutenu par la collectivité la
micro-région Ouest a bénéficié
d'investissement conséquents en matière
d'aménagement d'irrigation et de
valorisation du foncier agricole
l'objectif c'était donc que pour CBO le
propriétaire de récupérer ce foncier et
le département avec les fonds européens
et aussi la contrepartie apportée par la
collectivité départementale était de
réaménager ces sites pour les sortir de
la friche parce que c'était rien était
tombé en friche agricole et on est
aujourd'hui dans cette démarche ou à dit
2025 sur ces 750 hectares les 750
hectares seront exploités mais dans un
vrai projet agricole où on parle de
diversification on a de la
diversification plein champ des
différents diversification ici sous
abris mais ça montre qu'il y a un
potentiel important sur ces terrains de
l'antenne 4 c'est la passion a été mis
sur la diversification agricole qui
gagne du terrain sur l'antenne 4 avec la
visite de site de production de melon
d'ananas de mangue de fruits de la
passion et de vigne tu es en
installation sur de la production de Mel
hors sol sous abris donc c'est une
technique qu'on est en train de mettre
au point qui n'est pas terminé mais qui
à terme à mon avis sera à développer un
peu partout et ça te permet quand même
de sécuriser une production et aussi de
garantir un revenu pour pour
l'agriculteur produire du vin à la
Réunion
on a plusieurs difficultés
déjà en fait on est sur une zone
tropicale donc qui est qui amène
beaucoup de d'alternance entre pluie et
humidité et ensoleillement donc ça c'est
très propice au développement des
maladies mildiou et Audium qui attaque
le raisin donc c'est pour ça qu'en fait
on a ramené ici pour produire des bons
raisins des cépages résistants aux
maladies donc pour pas être obligé
d'utiliser trop de pesticides et comme
ça on va pouvoir
tenir compte de l'environnement et puis
essayer de pas
en 2017 il en reste actuellement 260 le
but étant de tous les exploiter en 2025
[Musique]